l a tutti ragazzi venuti a questo video
sono la vj e dolci siccome sabato siamo
in uno bloccato lo scorso sabato non è
uscito il blog
il tasso di suicidi in italia è
aumentato del 14 per cento
questo è un dato istat sono così
contento che siate così condizionati dal
fatto che debba uscire il video però sti
cazzi come al solito di ripartire con la
parte della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da aurora che ha
fatto un disegno figo ma direi di
passare alle news ragazzi perché ci sono
cose importantissime la prima
sconvolgerà la vostra esistenza questa
settimana ragazzi ho fatto un video su
just dance
per chi non l'avesse visto non si è
perso niente dai di sosta mi ha regalato
del dei gadget di just dance tra cui
questo un bastone per i selfin
el'utilità nel mio caso è semplicemente
quello di infilarlo nel culo ho provato
a usarlo o reale cioè il bastone dei
self i hanno regalato oddio mi hanno
regalato un bastone per i self i ma che
cazzo me ne faccio un bastone o infineon
alcun non so che cosa cazzo possa
centrare con just dance
però adesso che ci penso potrebbe essere
utile a qualcosa
ehi tu sei proprio tu ma non ti sei
accorto ha definito la carta igienica
avere il culo sporco di merda e non
avere la carta igienica per pulirsi è un
problema comune al giorno d'oggi quindi
tranquillizzati la carta igienica è
troppo lontana non chiamare e tua madre
che ti vedrà col culo sporco usa questo
i giorni cui trotterellavi nel bagno col
culo sporco sono finiti bastone dei self
i just dance e tutto ciò che ti serve
dalla vita
[Musica]
torna la settimana sono andato anche a
treviso ho fatto un raduno a treviso e
ho notato che la capezzolo mania di
perché i miei fan sono ossessionati dai
miei capezzoli perché tutti vorrebbero
leccarmi il capezzolo come ultima mi
chiamo antenne uso detto che poi non
sono news o stronzate
ma quando mai ho detto qualcosa di serio
in vita mia voglio aggiungere un nuovo
qualcosa di nuovo da fare nei blog che
mi è piaciuto un casino perché durante
la settimana ho fatto un video che si
intitola tu cosa faresti un videogame i
ragazzi che ti offre la possibilità di
scegliere tra due opzioni per i ragazzi
questo è il primo blog dove faccio il
primo tu cosa faresti
la proposta di oggi e non morirai mai di
malattia ma se accetti reina zanzara che
ti punge la la gamba per il resto della
tua vita
apple ha prendimi sono tu puoi avere
l'abilità di camminare attraverso i muri
ma i tuoi vestiti non verrebbero con te
immagino già io ho chiesto da un muro di
un mercatino in piazza duomo
schizza un cazzo addosso bellissimi
milioni di views si zio assolutamente
vuoi mangiare qualsiasi cosa vuoi e non
diventare ciccione questo già cielo c'è
già di mio e non so qual è il contro non
potrei mai più parlare al sesso opposto
io che posso parlare alla gnocca
posso anche mangiare non ingrassare allo
ragazzi questo era un assaggio per farvi
capire più o meno di cosa si tratta io
passerei aggiornato a cliccare il
bottone a casola che mi piace mi diverto
un bambino e parlando appunto di fare
risponde passiamo al fa vi risponde una
cosa nuova che non ho mai fatto in vita
mia
la prima domanda arriva da alexandre
regime a rispondere dove viene fa deejay
tv il concetto di tv è collegato al
telecomando nel senso che io ogni volta
che concludo il video faccio così e poi
siccome io
no no ma stavo schiacciate sono
[ __ ] per questo tipo ho avuto una
fantasia che minchia zio spostati e io
camera sono al tuo cantante preferito
non è martin garrison
ti prego si no ahmed fai fai la parodia
del video di belen delle tette
vabbè disse una coperta per voi che si
va bene così sono coperta per voi
così va bene o preferite casi alla
madonna
viva le tende mazza di gnocche cosa sto
facendo nella mia vita domenico grosso
sai che non puoi bloccare mark
zuckerberg su facebook
ma se in serie a
cazzo si ma basta ancora
[Musica]
ma chi cazzo ti credi di essere
fondatore di facebook io chi cazzo è chi
è ma no i tuoi capelli in confronto ai
miei non hai vinto t t cedola la
vittoria e anch'io faccio la doccia
costanti fare il figo ma non ti fare il
figo non ti chiamo ma ti chiamo 0
scherzo ride non ti piace è contento ma
comunque della tastiera che perde tasti
se avevi fa mi chiamavi tua nonna cosa
cazzo vuol dire ai ragazzi credo che le
domande su quel bottone siano più [ __ ]
di quelle che mi fate però siccome
voglio fare una cosa di spericolata
spericolato tra virgolette scrivetemi al
posto le domande stavolta delle sfide
non che siano tipo mangiati lo yogurt a
testa in giù che mi fanno schifo
roba un po più carina tipo tipo la
scelta quella del cesso e qualcuno della
ragazzina fari 90 di oggi è ispirata
questa abbiamo trovato l'utilità del
bastone dei se no ragazzi se vedete
qualcuno quel bastone di self in giro
prendete glielo allungate glielo è il
resto lo sapete da voi io non discrimino
le persone che utilizzano da stone e dei
set ma ci mancherebbe altro
io le prendo prova ammazzatevi di
ragazzi se il vino è piaciuto aveva
subito lasciato un commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook come un
invito a trattare tiziana senza vestiti
sky noi ci vediamo il provino bella
ragazza